so the one bit of advice i'd give to
someone considering starting a
recruitment company is decide whether
they want to go with it if it's a
lifestyle business then they can alter
it in a whole different way and they
need to consider is it worth leaving
your current company if so go for it if
you're a big biller and you want more
freedom go for it and if you want to
build something that doesn't exist right
now go back yourself and go for it as
well what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
so yeah a few checks come quick and fast
i've saved most of them there's a few
outlandish items but primarily i just
pumped it into property to be honest out
loud we want the outlandish
items come on um like i paid 800 pound
for a zip
one time that's it for a zip for a bag
so
bottles of champagne paint houses like
like but yeah like that wasn't i was a
slice of the pie like most of it i
didn't buy a car or anything like that
it was yeah what non-negotiable delivery
each day did you feel had a massive
impact on your productivity so my
non-negotiables are creating
non-negotiables for a to-do list so what
i've got to get out of that day and it
will happen no matter what i'm
prioritizing that and i won't leave
basically yeah till it's done final
question how do you think we can change
the perception of the equipment industry
each recruiter taking more
accountability for themselves is how i'd
say we can change industry and there's a
few things that um are working on
themselves that's going to raise the bar
as well but
that will be announced soon
[Music]
you